it's hard to concentrate because I can
see it on out right behind me and she's
staring right at me
haha the eyes are looking at all doesn't
matter find the kid she's coming after
oh yeah she doesn't have age no yeah we
were all kids once right yeah I watched
the film yesterday and then I slept at
the bathroom light on in my hotel room
that's seriously oh wow yeah perfect me
know that much which I loved what is it
about value at all no that is so
terrifying I didn't know the story when
I read the script but as soon as I
started talking about it with people
everybody
la I mean everybody I talked to knew
about it and they were and when I looked
her up and I saw the image of her and
this woman and though in the white
weeping the image was completely
familiar to me but I didn't know the
origin of the image and and that's me
was sort of fascinating about her she
seems to have been around forever yeah
like you're on that it's not she's not a
legend and forth you know we say oh
she's the legend but but I I feel like
glad you're La your honor is an entity
she has been with us for generations
ever since we were little and she
doesn't you know I'm from Venezuela I
grew up in Mexico and she doesn't just
have any borders it's not like okay you
left Mexico now she stay there she comes
with you and and she does you never
stopped believing in that your honor
there will always be a family member
including myself who maybe it hurt her
touch her saw her
mostly hurt her when my Alana is very
present she is a part of all of us and
there's just something extra creepy
about an entity that's come after
children oh there's just it's it's just
watching on camera or like you just want
to help the kids yeah there's something
that happens in the very beginning of
the script and I thought oh if they're
willing to do that yeah then all bets
are off and it's terrible it's a
terrifying concept but it set the tone
for the film you're absolutely right
today kind of shocking and then boom the
title card comes yeah did you do you
remember the first horror film not
really
I just like jaws affected me pretty hard
today and I don't think it's straight up
[ __ ] but it really it gave me a fear of
a healthy but not an unhealthy fear of
the ocean and then I still maintain and
I think I think millions of people
infected people and then I would have to
say Freddy Krueger
Oh Freddy you don't want to sleep yeah I
got already afraid to go to sleep as a
kid and then here's somebody with razor
blade hands we get you while you're on
am i good air I think for me was the
exercise
oh yeah it was so so much that I decided
not to watch horror films ever again
after that it affected you that much yes
yes I mean it's I think so much of the
Hispanic culture has to do you know with
the supernatural with the other world
said it kind of also explained why we
are so drawn to it is a way of how we
tell the stories of how our culture goes
through generations yeah but but now you
know doing this movie it's so great
because it has do we have an experience
to see it with the audience and it's
really odd falling in love before yeah I
mean I will have to work with I want to
go see more horror films and that's how
I looked about this film is I had so
much fun it scared me but it's so much
fun watching yes yeah what you want in a
horror film like laughing like nervously
but yeah sleeping with the light on at
night but it's all a good experience yes
I just wanted to really quickly trailer
drop through Netflix show say that you
kind of had this instant connection with
Christina Applegate because already even
though you're opposite characters from
what we can see there's such a good
connection I did actually she's she's
incredible I mean I watched her you know
forever like everybody else has she's
incredibly talented but she's a she's a
she's such a cool person and her and I
just I don't know we were instant
friends and partners and it just I think
it comes through and scream and I love
her and I couldn't done it without her
and we have I think we have something
really fun to show people how much fun
it was your character to play so much
funny she's so
different I mean it's night and day from
from Green Book from everything else
I've done I think it's a really fun
character I think it's a it's a it's a
really fun turn for me
you